public sénat france 24 et rfi présente
[Musique]
on
bonjour à tous merci de nous rejoindre
pour ici l'europe en cette semaine de
reconfirmer généralisée des pays
européens nous avons le plaisir de
rejoindre en duplex de paris où ils se
trouvent comme nous mais nos invités
doivent se tenir désormais à distance en
réel gurria bonjour merci d'être avec
nous bonjour andrei gorilla vous êtes
depuis 2006 secrétaire général de l'
ocde l'organisation de coopération et de
développement économiques qui compte à
ce jour 37 pays membres parmi les plus
riches de la planète vous achevé en juin
prochain juin 2021
votre troisième mandat à la tête de
cette organisation multilatérale
vous y avez connu des hauts et des bas
des avancées en matière de lutte contre
l'évasion fiscale par exemple mais la
pandémie de kovy 19 est venu démontrer
les insuffisances de la coopération
internationale et puis surtout le ton
d'un mandat à la tête des états unis le
président trump a considérablement abîmé
ce multilatéralisme qui vous est cher
alors en tant qu'observateur en chef des
pays riches
vous notez un confinement généralisée et
désordonnée face aux coronavirus la
pandémie impact grandement à la
croissance mondiale et pourrait
déboucher d'ailleurs sur un recours
recul du pipe de 4,5 pour cent pour 2020
est-ce que l'on va au devant de la pire
crise de notre histoire sans doute c'est
la pire crise de l'histoire de l'eau ces
deux mêmes 1 60 ans on n'a jamais fait
des projections si négatif on va avoir
une chute de 4 10% du piv mondiale pour
l'année 2000 ventes mais c'est qui est
important aujourd'hui c'est que cette
deuxième vague des l'infection de virus
menace et la récupération menace la
reprise économique parce que et il
semble qu'on va entrer dans le 2021 et
avec une faible reprise à cause de cette
deuxième vague alors ça va provoquer que
naturellement les les perspectives
économiques des deux reprises de travail
investissements etc pour l'année 2020
soit plus faible alors andré goule rien
vous avez appelé les européens à mieux
se coordonner
par rapport à cette pandémie de kovy de
19 ils ont annoncé un plan de relance à
hauteur de 750 milliards d'euros
un plan inédit mais aujourd'hui on est
en pleine deuxième vague est ce que
c'est déjà trop faible cette annonce je
dirais que l'annoncent de 750 milliards
et était en deux plus importants
concernant et l'unité et la cohésion
européenne
ça va au delà de la question de la
pandémie ça va au delà de la question du
commerce sur la question de
l'investissement et ça c'est la première
fois dans lesquels l'europe et anne
accord pour partager le risque mais
aussi pour que le plus fort aides et
appuis les plus faibles et dans le
domaine du crédit dans le domaine des
accès et au financement mais aussi dans
la question de la réduction des spreads
sur la dette
alors je crois que c'est un événement
d'une importance énorme que peut être à
cause de toutes les discussions de
procédures acceptera n est pas si
évident pour tout les européennes pour
céder nous que vous en servez de deshors
même pour un mexique m mais pour une
organisation comme l' ocde qui est né
précisément pour la reconstruction de
l'europe
c'est un moment énormément importante
est naturellement avec beaucoup de
promesses
alors vous venez de tirer tout de même
la sonnette d'alarmé à l' ocde à propos
des financements privés vers les pays
pauvres - 700 milliards de dollars en
moins cette année des populations qui
reçoivent également moins d'argent
venant de la diaspora y compris celle
qui est en europe installé
comment compenser pour éviter
l'effondrement économique de ces pays
déjà il était est faible mais avant mais
avec le co vide toutes ses faiblesses et
se sont développées encore plus et
option devenue et beaucoup beaucoup plus
évident et il faut faire un énorme
effort vis-à-vis les pays émergents tu
parce que et il a une chute on les colts
nous le calculons 700 millions contre
7,5 milliards qu'on a
vous l'avez évoqué deux des flux vers
les pays en développement mais aussi il
y avait déjà un déficit de flux et de ce
qu'ils ont besoin pour se développer
mais aujourd'hui ils ont eu une
augmentation des dépenses des frais à
cause précisément de la pandémie et et
toute l'aide au développement
tout 753 milliards par an ah ça veut
dire qu'on peut la doubler
on peut la triple iq et 4,4 oublie
qu'elle est et ça pourrait aller est
très très loin en terme de ces ce qu'ils
ont besoin et parce que si vous voyez et
les les pays les plus riches ont déjà
dédié puis de 12000 milliards d'euros
contre
la pandémie sévère qu'avec une toute
petite fraction avec avec pas seulement
générosité mais aussi sagesse et
intelligence parce que jusqu'aux
dernières cas de virus s'étend dans les
pays en développement
on boit pas jeter victoire alors
l'annoncent d'un vaccin se précise il
pourrait être mis en circulation sous
peu est ce que ça nous permet
d'entrevoir le bout du tyne et du tunnel
et puis la date vous pensez que c'est
pour quand ce vaccin et j'espère que ces
deux failles serre et biotech sera pas
l'unique mai et ça et nous permet de
changer un peu les expectatives mais
vraiment quand est ce qu'on espère que
et les vaccine seront disponibles pour
tout le monde pas seulement ceux qui
l'on veut soi mais pour la majorité de
la population peu ça je crois qu on aura
un 1 année ventes 21 dans lesquels pour
la majorité de l'année
il faudra apprendre à vivre avec le
virus pendant que la vaccine se
développe
ça prouve ce produit mais aussi ses
produits et ses distribue à tout et les
pays et incluent les pays en
développement où il ya besoin alors en
guerre gurria la compétition pour le
vaccin risque-t-elle malgré tout de
couper le monde en deux et de creuser
les inégalités
il faut faire et de la vaccine un bien
public
ça veut dire quelque chose qui est
disponible pour ceux qui ont besoin et
c'était suggéré que le coc soignants
pour être les premières je serai
totalement d'accord et les les les vieux
naturellement qu'ils sont plus plus
les fables mais il y aura un moment dans
lesquelles ça va être nécessaire d'avoir
la grande majorité de la population du
monde d'aujourd'hui parce que et sinon
et et on va avoir des des lieux on va
avoir des pays dans lesquels on va avoir
des explosions de deux virus
vous êtes aussi confiant par rapport à
la réintégration des états unis au sein
de l'organisation mondiale de la santé
puisque donald trump a suspendu les
financements est ce que vous appelez joe
biden à se réinvestir dans l' oms
absolument je crois que c'est ce n'est
pas seulement une organisation
particulière c'est le ms parce que on à
la pandémie aujourd'hui ça devient très
très évident mais c'est aussi l'accord
de paris pour le changement climatique
mais c'est aussi une escaut par exemple
alors et c'est une question de
l'attitude générale vis-à-vis le
multilatéralisme et ça c'est très très
important et ça et je crois que beaucoup
des promesses avec 7
c'est nouveau gouvernement le président
trompe vous l'avez mentionné il a aussi
paralysé
l'om s'est retiré des accords de paris
pourtant on a l'impression que ce rejet
du multilatéralisme
il va survivre à sa présidence aux états
unis dans le monde
il se développe au sia est ce que ce
mouvement ne vous inquiète pas je dirais
que la question de multilatéralisme et
c'est pas seulement la meilleure manière
d adresser certains problèmes et c'est
l'unique manière d'adresser et la
question du commerce
la question des investissements et
transfrontalières et la question de la
la
le climat naturellement là la
biodiversité et la question et de la
migration est naturellement la question
de la pandémie
on est aujourd'hui confronté avec le
phénomène le plus le plus universel le
le pli panne
je n'insiste dans le la partie panne de
la panique parce que c'est partout et
naturellement il faut un effort global
alors prenons le dossier des géants du
numérique le dossier de la taxation des
gaffes âme les européens veulent taxer
ces multinationales qui ne payent pas de
sol sur deux d'impôt pardon sur le sol
européen
est-ce que vous pensez que les états
unis là aussi vont revenir à la table
des négociations parce que vous aviez
commencé à progresser et puis les états
unis ont claqué la porte de ces
discussions à l' ocde pour les
etats-unis mais pour tous les pays du
monde la meilleure chose c'est un accord
international passe pourquoi parce que
l'alternative c'est une guerre
commerciale
encore une autre et nous savons déjà
quel est le prix que sont les
conséquences des tensions commerciales
même avant le coc vide on avait une
croissance presque plate à cause des
tensions commerciales parce que le flux
d'investissement ont chuté et on sait
déjà quelles sont les conséquences sur
le pourquoi aller vers un chemin qui
vous conduisent à une guerre commerciale
pourrait pourquoi pas ce que si chaque
pays prend des décisions sur la taxation
de digital qui sont nationales seulement
nationale et il y à un autre pays qui
interprète que c'est contre les les
entreprises de ce pays
ici dans ce cas les états unis et les
pays européens
ça veut dire que on aura une encore une
guerre commerciale la solution doit être
un accord international
on est presque là et on a reporté de
décembre jusqu'à mi 2021 pour achever sa
mais je crois que on va le faire
et seulement parce que les conséquences
comme jeudi et son peuple sont si
négative alors autre potentiel conflit
commercial
hélas le temps presse encore plus
puisqu'il s'agit de la fin de cette
année gros sujet de préoccupation pour
les européens pour vous aussi
toujours pas d'accord commercial avec
les britanniques et les 27
vous prévoyez un brésil d'ailleurs sans
accord qui aurait quel impact selon vous
sur la croissance à la fois européenne
et peut-être mondiale
il y a un impact au niveau mondial
dépend de vie de l'ambiance il y a un
impact au niveau européenne acoss 2e un
partenaire importante qui parle mais qui
n'a pas un accord commercial
après ça mais c'est surtout un impact
sur le royaume uni
alors je moi je ne perds pas là la
confiance que finalement on va aboutir
un accord mais je dirais que les
conséquences les coudes serrés surtout
pour les britanniques entre le gorilla
juste avant de se quitter
parlons votre succession à la tête de l'
ocde puisque vous terminez votre mandat
en juin
alors qui voyez vous comme profil idéal
pour la suite
un proche de donald trump qui était
jusque-là pressentis ou plutôt une femme
une ancienne femme commissaire
européenne il y a dix candidats les dix
sont très qualifiés sont
et ils ont honte et des expériences très
très diversifiée parce qu'il ya ce qui
était ministre des finances ministre du
commerce
et il ya ceux qui s'étaient mis son
environnement il est à ceux qui qui ont
participé dans des dédales de les les
accord commercial etc
et je dirais que c'est qui est très
important c'est que et le le
multilatéralisme
soit c'est qui mène les travaux de
l'oscd dans le futur comme nous l'avons
est menée et de que nous avons menées et
pendant les devenir 15 ans pourquoi
parce que quand j'évoquais avant c'est
l'unique manière d'adresser beaucoup des
problèmes global il y à une
globalisation qu'inévitable il ya un
digital isation qu'inévitable de par
définition ça expliquerait peut-être le
proche de donald trump angel gurria
merci de cette interview
merci à vous bien sûr de nous avoir
suivis vous restez en notre compagnie
car je vais être rejointe tout de suite
sur ce plateau par marie brémaud de
public sénat et trois eurodéputés qui
vont nous parler de l'europe mobilisé
contre la seconde vague de coronavirus a
tout de suite
[Musique]
bienvenue pour la seconde partie de nos
débats nous ne sommes pas au parlement
européen de bruxelles confinement oblige
mais nous avons convié à distance trois
eurodéputés pour se pencher sur l'europe
face à la seconde vague du coronavirus
l'europe a dépassé 300 mille morts
depuis le début de la pandémie les
courbes ont grimpé dangereusement depuis
la rentrée générant partout der
confinement partiels ou totaux
les mesures restrictives ont été
accueillis parfois par des
manifestations mais cette crise a
paradoxalement pour booster la
compétence de bruxelles en matière de
santé la commission a dévoilé mercredi
son grand projet d'union de la santé
pour se donner les moyens d'affronter
deux futures crises sanitaires elle
préconise des mesures de coordination
ainsi que la création d'une nouvelle
agence européenne era la health
emergency response of equity et la
vaccination 1 des européens plutôt bien
coordonné depuis bruxelles n'est plus
qu'une question de mois alors pour
analyser les différentes réponses des
pays membres et débattre des mesures les
plus appropriées nous rejoignons à
strasbourg fabienne keller oro députée
française renew europe
nous sommes aussi avec tiziana béguines
bonjour eurodéputés du mouvement 5
étoiles au pouvoir chez les non inscrits
au parlement européen depuis alexandria
en italie et puis deux puis à bruxelles
au parlement européen marque bottega
député européen belge de la gauche
unitaire européenne la belgique un mark
bowden gars qui vit une seconde vague
particulièrement violente
l'une des plus dures en europe à qui la
faute
je pense qu'il ya une une série de
facteurs structurels qui explique que la
belgique est évidemment vulnérable donc
on est au centre on est à un carrefour
on a une densité au niveau de la
population qui est importante mais je
pense qu'il ya aussi juste un manque de
préparation je veux dire notre
gouvernement essaie de jouer le coup de
on a été surpris mais c'est depuis mars
que tout le monde annonçait deuxième
vague et force est de constater que nous
n'étions pas prêts mettions pas prêts au
niveau du testing au niveau du duduk
racing donc le dépistage le suivi et non
plus alors l'isolément tandis que
c'était la base
donc ça c'est un je pense un premier
problème un deuxième problème a été
toute la cacophonie entre régions ou les
uns ne voulait pas prendre les mesures
des autres et vice versa donc il ya un
manque de zon de coordination vraiment
national un certain moment et finalement
je pense qu'il ya un grand tabou en
belgique et c'est celui des victimes ou
des contaminations qui se font sur le
lieu de travail
on ne peut pas en parler on n'a pas les
chiffres tandis qu on a vu qu'à
l'inspection sociale belge a constaté
que dans les inspections effectuées sur
le lieu de travail
environ 50% des entreprises n'étaient
pas en ordre avec les mesures sanitaires
imposées par le gouvernement alors
fabienne keller le premier ministre
castex vient de redire qu'il fallait
plus de temps plus de temps de
confinement un nouveau tour de vis en
quelque sorte la france elle n'a pas
bien tirer les enseignements de la
première vague et elle sert contaminés
alors la france vit comme les pays
d'europe cette deuxième vague
ce deuxième confinement est très
différent du premier
puisque les établissements scolaires
écoles collèges lycées fonctionne en
présentiel c'est très important pour la
jeunesse pour les parents bien sûr aussi
il de ce fait peuvent aller où on
prendre le temps de travailler soit si
c'est indispensable sur le lieu à bail
soit en privé des gens chaque fois que
possible le télétravail donc un
confinement et socialement mieux
acceptée et bien sûr cela dure
cela est difficile donc le premier
ministre hier a confirmé le
maintien en particulier de la fermeture
des commerces non essentiels donc ça
c'est difficile dans cette période avant
noël et puis certaines activités
toujours interdites comme par exemple
les clubs de sport tout ce qui est en
salles fermées assez logiquement
d'ailleurs n'est pas rée autorisé pour
l'instant mais une prise de conscience
au sein de toute la population qui quand
même effort des mesures barrières ils
sont plus pour bien appliquer le fait
d'ailleurs qu'elles soient enseignées
expliqué dans les établissements
scolaires et est précieux donc voila
nous essayons de préserver noël comme
l'a dit le premier ministre l'italie a
dépassé 1 mercredi le million de cas
enregistrés une épidémie hors de
contrôle au sud est la discipline est
difficile à instaurer un dans un climat
de remise en cause des mesures avec des
manifestations violentes à naples turin
rome et milan comment vous expliquer
cette remise en cause des mesures pour
quoi bon en effet il faut dire que les
manifestations qui ont eu lieu il ya
quelques jours avait fait on était assez
violent et on avoue aussi qui a été con
ça passe souvent il faut le dire
l'occasion pour les extrémistes qui rien
à avoir avec les justes manifestation de
certains opérateurs économiques qui se
sont bien sentis et dames âgées par des
mesures qui me qui vise à contenir la
pandémie mais en effet comme vous avez
bien en y maintenant c'est pas pareil
partout en italie mais la situation est
bien sûr
très compliqué il y a des raisons que le
nord de l'italie la ligue aurait pas
encore cessé d'en face une façon moyenne
des risques on a partagé les cali en
trois
il y à un niveau jaune au niveau orange
au niveau rouge
les indicateurs nous dit que naples va
arriver dans un dans une situation rouge
donc ça signifie de risques très élevés
alors que 6ème en vie précisément
margotin gare voyez que votre collègue
elle met le doigt sur quelque chose le
manque de coordination pour les
définitions de ces fameux zone rouge
manque de coordination européenne pour
la mobilité qui reste très défaillante
pourquoi on n'a pas tiré profit des mois
passés pour renforcer cette coordination
la verrouillant en quelque sorte pour
une prochaine vague
je pense que il ya une une vérité très
simple c'est que l'europe l'union
européenne étaient construites en
premier lieu comme un espace de
concurrence non pas comme un espace de
co de coopération elle veut dire on l'a
vu lors de la première vague et faut
arrêter de dire que c'est pas vrai il ya
une concurrence économique entre les
états et ça ça a joué je veux dire les
états qui étaient sous pression aussi
par leurs organisations patronales pour
ne pas fermer certaines endroits et c
est bon du coup quand il ya cette
concurrence vous voyez bien qu'il y va
nous on va pas prendre des mesures trop
strictes ou non coordonnés avec d'autres
tandis que les autres essayent de nous
avoir d'auxi à cet esprit-là de
concurrence de lutte des uns contre les
autres
d'un point de vue économique évidemment
c'est un impact sur la coordination
sanitaire qui peut se faire et qui
devrait se faire
je pense est extrêmement important et
deuxièmement je pense quand même par
rapport à l'acceptation des mesures
effectivement ce serait plus logique et
mieux si on avait au niveau européen des
zones
comparable ou des critères comparables
mais quelle à la question de la
cohérence des mesures jeu va quand même
se poser parce que on peut pas expliquer
qu'on puisse pas voir nos parents nos
amis mais que par contre on peut aller
travailler à des centaines dans une
entreprise où les mesures de sécurité ne
sont pas respectées
donc cette contradiction là il faut la
gérer aussi et si on n'arriverait pas à
gérer effectivement les gens seront de
plus en plus réticents par rapport à ces
mesures on entend les des films il ya
tout de même une bonne nouvelle dans
tout ça l'union européenne vient de
présenter l'union de la santé un plan
européen de préparation aux crises
sanitaires
déclinée au niveau national avec audités
tests de résistance réguliers et
systèmes de surveillance intégrée c'est
un progrès tiziana béguines cette union
de la santé oui oui je pense que oui
parce que l effet ce plan qui a été
présenté par la commissaire celle là et
qu'elle y at il essai en première
10% à rassembler une grande révolution
mais il ya quelque chose qui est
vraiment forts comme la possibilité pour
le centre européen pour le contrôle des
maladies de formuler des recommandations
politiques et ça c'est vraiment quelque
chose de nouveau
bien sûr il n'y a rien qui modifie les
les traités de l'union européenne ont
les compétences des proxy pour ce qui
concerne les synthétiques une fois
rappeler qu'ils sont pour la plupart
compétence des états membres mais en
effet avec cette non on a beaucoup plus
de possibilités et surtout la la
formation de cette nouvelle agence lra
qui peut développer des
des nouveaux protocoles on peut dire et
même en plus pour coordonner nos
intérêts et gérer la capacité de
production de développement des
médicaments des dispositifs de
protection et sert peut aider surtout
dans une période où on a vu que les
problèmes ont été même liées à la chaîne
d'approvisionnement de des instruments
qui étaient coupées qui n'était pas
suffisant pour tout pour tout l'or et
des petits pas en direction d'un majeur
mais alors précisément fabienne keller
une nouvelle agence européenne era m
emergency response l'autorité qui
devrait voir le jour en 2023 seulement
cela paraît bien loin alors que
l'urgence du coronavirus et là alors il
faut aussi rappeler factuellement que
l'europe n'a pas de compétence dans le
domaine de la santé en tout cas n'en
avaient pas jusque là et c'est bien de
manière volontaire eux sous le coup du
chacun de la lépi l'hélico vie que les
états membres ont décidé d'une part de
la création de cette agence du
renforcement de la ligue européenne
s'est dit si le centre pour le contrôle
des épidémies et également alors ça
c'est la très bonne nouvelle du début de
cette semaine de se doter d'un programme
et you for health donc l'europe pour la
santé dont le budget a finalement été
triplée par rapport à ce qui était
initialement prévu donc un progrès au
niveau 1 mais aussi des progrès sur le
terrain moi je le vis ici à strasbourg à
la frontière allemande
alors que la première vague s'était
traduite par une fermeture des
frontières
là il y a des coordinations très
régulières entre la préfète et les
autorités du bade wurtemberg et les
dispositions nationales et au niveau du
land sont chaque fois discuté évalué
réfléchi ensemble donc une europe en
crêpe
il avance aussi pour mieux lutter
ensemble contre l'épidémie
alors que bien sûr on a des travailleurs
frontaliers en personne
qui ont des habitudes d'aller vivre des
familles qui vivent des deux côtés du
rhin donc aussi une europe du concrètes
qui fait progresser cette europe de la
santé que désormais nous appelons tous
de nouveau autre bonne nouvelle un
bruxelles est capable également de
coordonner l'achat en commun de deux
vaccins elle vient d'approuver un contre
avec le vaccin un prometteur de kaiser
tout en ayant sécurisé an les commandes
à quatre autres groupes pharmaceutiques
les européens margot tenga ils ne vont
pas manquer de vaccins contre le corona
virus faut dire que ces contrats ne
garantissent en rien que tous les
européens auront accès à un vaccin
ça c'est une première chose deuxièmement
ces vaccins effectivement ça a un sens
de négocier collectivement ensemble avec
l'industrie pharmaceutique
le grand problème c'est que la
commission le fait en cachette donc nous
ne savons rien ni sur le prix ni sur les
conditions et donc ce que nous avons
découvert disons par des fuites n'est
pas rassurant pourquoi c'est pas
rassurant parce que on surpayent des
médicaments des vaccins qui n'existait
pas encore des vaccins que nous avons
déjà financés dans l'étape de recherche
et développement donc nous avons payé
recherche et développement du vaccin
nous payons maintenant l'expansion de la
capacité de production est tout à
l'heure nous allons payer l'achat de ces
vaccins moi je pense qu'il ya un grand
problème que si on paye tout ça et après
on n'a même pas la garantie que tous les
européens
et je ne parle pas encore du reste du
monde auront accès à un vaccin c'est
qu'il ya un problème avec le modèle et
moi je me pose la question si vraiment
on veut garantir que tout le monde est
un vaccin ou un médicament et que ce
soit accessible et disponible
pourquoi est-ce qu'on développe à une
capacité de production public plutôt que
de laisser ça aux aux industries
pharmaceutiques privées qui dominent le
secteur de la santé aujourd'hui ça
serait une europe de la santé qui
garantit à ses citoyens des médicaments
et des vaccins et pas nous laisser
encore une fois dans les mains de ces
multinationales qui ne veut faire qu'une
chose c'est faire du profit et moi j'ai
demandé hier en plénière à la commission
européenne de publier ces contrats ce
qu'elle refuse de faire et je trouve que
ça ça n'inspire pas confiance alors
précisément fabienne keller la
présidente de la commission à la promis
une répartition équitable entre les 27
états membres
est ce que ça sera vrai aussi
avec des citoyens européens riches ou
pauvres est ce que tout le monde
bénéficiera de ces vaccins moi je me
réjouis que d'un commun accord les états
membres est confiée à la commission
la gestion des relations avec les
vaccins potentiels
évidemment un grand espoir pour nous
tous des critères de répartition seront
sereinement discuter évidemment il
s'agit de préserver à vent ou les pays
les plus touchés et dans ces pays les
populations les plus fragiles en ayant
en tête aussi que la vaccination
généralisée permet de protéger ceux qui
pour des raisons de santé ne peuvent pas
accepter d'être vacciné e mène un set en
vaccinant l'environnement pour protège
aussi les plus fragiles
moi je trouve que c'est une très belle
démonstration 2 fait de la puissance de
l'europe ah c'est vrai à un groupe
pharmaceutique puissant pour négocier
une sécurité des vaccins et puis à long
terme je suis d'accord avec ce qui vient
d'être dit c'est la question de la
souveraineté en termes de recherche et
de capacités de production des
médicaments comme des et vaccins on a
pris conscience de notre grande
dépendance
d'ailleurs dans le monde 1 en asie en
inde en chine
il est temps on reconstruit une vraie
industrie eu une recherche avec
suffisamment de moyens aussi pour être
en capacité de maîtriser ce qui est
absolument stratégique à la protection
de nos concitoyens
on l'entend pour conclure tiziana begin
aux danois douze personnes touchées par
une mutation du virus et le pays a
abattu ou à va abattre 15 millions de
vison pour ce qui concerne
les maisons je pense que c'était quelque
chose de vraiment horrible pour ce qui
concerne la notation de nouveau virus se
il y as en débat ces propos je parle
beaucoup je coûte beaucoup de médecins
qui sont experts un malade qui a maladie
est effective et a laissé il ya bien sûr
aussi des doutes sur la possibilité que
le vaccin soit efficace il ya plusieurs
choses à considérer et même l annonce
des prises d'air sur les vaccins c'est
la possibilité d'être et picasso 90% qui
est vraiment énorme et mais doit tous
être encore vérifié
merci en tout cas effectivement beaucoup
d'incertitudes autour de secours au
navire us encore pour l'europe merci à
vous d'avoir très bien de participer à
ce débat
merci à vous de nous avoir suivis vous
restez sur nos antennes pour la suite de
nos programmes
[Musique]